はいこんにちははじめ社長ですねこれから暑くなるかなぁこういう夏のスタイルがこれ
から飲もうと栄養素なんですよ
お前覚えだけ男は髪型で気になる
そんなこともないちょっと買い物に行ってきたわけなんですよどうぞ a
おっせえいって今日はですねこちらに反応メカもたくさん買ってきました
目が音の小さい版ですね中身は代替案こんな感じか安っぽいな
こういうこういう奴めがファンなんですけども
電池何こそのたまさんこれはそもそもまたうんさんでしかけるロック
12345678864じゃなく48分もいるのよ
そいつ電車入れますうわすマジか
はぁっはぁっはぁっ
はぁっじゃあこれで5作らず
ああああっ
アーキンぬううううううっうぅううかあっ入っ夏こちらのあーヌーを使う路線駅
をこいつが聞いて大きくなるで親思ったわけ俺がしゃべった声のこいつが聞いて大きく
しで
でコンビがもがしゃべった声をさらに他の女の本が聞いて大きくしてさらにこの王 tv
が方が効いた音こっちがを聞いて
これが男れ大きくでこれほどこれ言ってこれもがこれをつくって校園前よく人俺の声の
無限に交流
そして音の台風ができるそれがとか守ってあげなきゃよ俺頭悪いな俺でもできると思っ
てるかな
原理としてはメガホン2が音をちーてそのうと大きくなって出すっていうビッグボタン
を取ると中で恋前に円陣を組みますこういう感じ
こういう感じ
これ目玉で円陣を組むんですけども演説文ですけど僕じゃあバーって言うじゃん
これにねあーんっていう通すの俺の愛がここから大きな音であってる
2つの大きなターンこのメガホンが俺のあを拾いますからねこんなメガホンたちと
アーサーにこれが拾って
でこれの青これですよでこれを色ちろちろうしろん白チャ7
2あああああ
結婚たそーくやってみたいいと思います
消極いかず
ま常に夫の原作をしているということか
なんとかどうなんで
終わったが観客はけら別を乱すな館活動時の男女4交互に並べ
だから男子同士公募になるって
ぞんでもって俺は代打オレこれ近所雅で追い出されちゃう観客出せないとなんか変な
共鳴を見たいなら出すんでパンク広めでいきたいですね
お前何で woody
チームせまたまたまたです山井が違ったことどうするっていうのはコレ
座ってない変な音質なんですけど苦情くるよこれは俺はこんなのはなきゃいけないんで
一回だけフルパワーでとりあえず全部つなげてみましょうやるしかねぇ
ではいきます全部門
ます
tee